Iceman: Ace fighter pilot,
volleyball enthusiast… and
the real hero of the Top Gun franchise?
It might not be as crazy as it sounds.
Top Gun was penned by the screenwriting
team of Jack Epps Jr. and Jim Cash, who,
in the 1980s, were two of the hottest
writers in the business. As they worked
on the Top Gun script, they realized on one
level that it's actually more of a sports
film than a war movie — which opened up many new
possibilities for their story. As Epps explains:
“From my point of view as a writer,
'Top Gun' is a sport is a sport movie,
and the sport is ACM: Aerial Combat Maneuvering."
Much like in the world of sports, Top
Gun features a lot of young talent who
are eager to prove themselves. To that end,
the writers set a number of important scenes
in locker rooms — mostly because this is
a place where the characters can speak to
each other in a manner that might not
be possible when they're in uniform.
It's not clear whether the characters in
Top Gun are based on real people or not,
but some people believe that Iceman was indeed
based on a real-life fighter pilot. According to
the military publication Stars and Stripes, Ice
was based on a fighter pilot named Deniz Tek,
who went by the same callsign. Tek played
guitar in a cult band called Radio Birdman
and studied medicine in Australia. Once
he got back to the United States in 1981,
he joined the Navy and became a flight surgeon.
According to Tek himself, the makers of
Top Gun spent time with his squadron doing
research for the film. In fact, one
of Tek's old military buddies said:
"The characters seem so similar. He was
even more intense than the movie Iceman."
Yet Jack Epps Jr., who co-wrote the
film, said the character wasn't based
on any real-life military man, insisting
that basing their characters on real
people might have brought up unwanted
legal problems for the film's crew.
In the movie Sleep With Me, Quentin
Tarantino delivered a riff on Top Gun,
claiming that it's actually a gay movie in
disguise. Since then, numerous theories have
popped up online about the apparent homoerotic
subtext of Top Gun. But David Paul Kirkpatrick,
a former executive at Paramount, says this
wasn't intentional. He wrote on Facebook:
"Much has been made of the [...]
homo-erotic nature of Top Gun,
particularly the volleyball sequence,
but it wasn't intentional. The guys in
the movie were young and in good
shape for their respective parts,
and Tony Scott shot the scene quickly at
magic hour which gave it that golden glow."
Kirkpatrick continued:
"The volleyball sequence stayed in the movie only
because the women adored the scene in previews.
It's because the sequence exhibited non-toxic
masculinity at its finest — non-aggressive
Greek gods playing ball slathered in
suntan lotion and wearing Ray Bans."
In later years, however, the film attracted
a significant gay following, and it brought
many in touch with their sexuality at a young
age. As Robert W. Fieseler explained in Slate:
"Iceman and Maverick jetted lifesaving
homoeroticism past a generation of
conservative parents [...] No adult, not
even a minister, would bat an eyelash when
I said knowingly to their sons—kids I hoped were
closeted gay, too—'Top Gun is my favorite film.'"
It actually took some convincing to get Val
Kilmer to commit to Top Gun. As Kilmer recalled,
he and Cruise had the same agent, so he knew
about the project. But he wasn't convinced.
"I just really wasn't interested in it. I liked
Tony Scott very much, but I turned it down."
As Kilmer remembered, director
Tony Scott then ran after Kilmer,
got in front of the elevator so
he couldn't leave, and told him:
"You've gotta do it man! It's gonna be great! And
he described with this enthusiasm and
relish how it was going to be seen."
Kilmer was finally won over
by his enthusiasm — although
a number of contractual obligations
to Paramount helped things along.
In a movie full of cocky young guys out to
prove themselves, it would only be natural
there would be some tension offscreen
as well. Whether there was indeed any
true rivalry between Tom Cruise and Val Kilmer is
unclear, but they certainly kept their distance.
Often, when actors play rivals in a film,
they'll stay away from each other while the
movie is shooting. On Top Gun, Kilmer stayed close
with his onscreen buddies Hollywood and Wolfman,
while Maverick and Goose stayed tight.
Cruise also stayed out of any of the
offscreen partying that Kilmer and his Top Gun
buddies got involved in. Kilmer later said:
"I would purposely play up the rivalry
between Tom's character and mine off
screen as well. It was fun to play up
the conflict between our characters,
but in reality, I've always thought of Tom as a
friend, and we've always supported each other."
Not all was well on the Top Gun set, though.
In a documentary on the making of the movie,
Kilmer said he believed Cruise might
have sabotaged the footage from the
volleyball game. Tony Scott apparently
told Kilmer the shots featuring him had
been "cooked," meaning they were over or
under-developed, and unusable for the film.
In order to deliver their best
performances, many actors craft
backstories for the characters they play.
The audience may never know about this,
but it's nevertheless important for
actors to have something to draw on
when they perform. When Kilmer agreed to
play Iceman, he created a backstory for
the character that gave him some added depth.
As the actor said in his documentary, Val:
"On the page, there was very little to
the character Iceman. So I attempted to
make him real. I manifested a backstory for
him, where he had a father who ignored him,
and as a result, was driven by the
need to be perfect in every way.
This obsession with perfections
is what made him so arrogant."
This backstory brings so much more to Top Gun
because Maverick struggles with similar issues,
as he desperately seeks to live up to
his late father's legend as a pilot.
Top Gun i s a story that inspired audiences around
the world. It was the number one movie of 1986,
making $176 million at the domestic
box office. Since starring in the film,
Kilmer has been recognized as Iceman
for over three decades by pilots — and
the film famously increased military enlistment.
Reportedly, the U.S. Navy had more applications
than they'd had in years after the success of
Top Gun, and there have been reports that the
film made naval recruiting increase by 500%,
though this figure may have been exaggerated.
At the same time, as one Navy vet said:
"I saw the movie, thought it looked like the
most exciting job in the world. And it is."
In recent years, the Navy has been having
problems enlisting new recruits; it remains
to be seen whether Top Gun: Maverick
will turn this around for the service.
Tom Cruise was clearly the star of Top Gun, and
he starred in the film right as he was becoming
one of the hottest actors in Hollywood. In
recent years, however, some fans have come
to realize how important Iceman is to the
story, with many even believing that he is
the real hero of the movie. In one critique
at Collider, for example, the writer noted:
"Iceman is just as essential
to the success of the final
mission where Maverick gets all [his] acclaim."
In the end, Maverick gets all the glory,
but Maverick is more traditionally heroic,
both as a pilot and as a character. As many other
fans point out, Maverick himself is reckless and
dangerous, but Iceman is cool under pressure and
far more together than the young protagonist,
who strives to prove he's a real hotshot.
And whether you think he's the hero or not,
there's no question Iceman is a crucial component
in the Top Gun storyline — after all, without him,
Maverick's character arc and growth wouldn't
be anywhere near as dramatic or compelling.
"Who's the better pilot, you or me?"
"This is a nice moment. Let's not ruin it."
Although Tom Cruise is the
star of Top Gun: Maverick,
the fact that Iceman returned for a brief but
memorable segment shows there is still plenty
of goodwill for the character. In fact,
as producer Jerry Bruckheimer explained:
"Tom said he wasn't going to
make the movie without him."
Cruise confirmed this, too. As he recalls:
"I really rallied hard for him to make
the movie. The kind of talent that he has,
and you see that scene, it's very special."
Cruise apparently told Bruckheimer
that Kilmer simply had to come back
for the second Top Gun movie. It was a
wonderful reunion for Bruckheimer, too,
who had worked with Kilmer
on the original Top Gun.
While Val Kilmer was initially skittish about
taking on the role of Iceman in the original Top
Gun, he was reportedly delighted that his
character is still so beloved by fans and
filmmakers. That's exactly why he signed on to
one of the biggest box office hits of all time,
with Top Gun: Maverick. In fact,
as Jerry Bruckheimer explained:
"We called Val and told him we wanted to meet
him to be in the picture. And he was thrilled."
And as Kilmer's son Jack told People magazine:
"They honor the legacy of Iceman,
and he was so stoked by it."
When Jack and his sister Mercedes went
down to the San Diego naval base where
Maverick was shooting, real-life navy
pilots came up to them and told them
that Top Gun had inspired them to
join the armed forces. Jack said:
"It was one of the proudest moments of being
American that you could think of really."
Against all odds, especially with Kilmer's
speaking voice being so badly damaged,
Kilmer's scene with Cruise in Maverick makes
for one of the movie's most powerful moments.
Kilmer later said that, when Iceman and
Maverick hug in their scene together:
"[It was] straight from the heart. I love Tom."
On Top Gun: Maverick, Val Kilmer had a hand
in developing Iceman's story. In the sequel,
Iceman has moved up to admiral, and his life is
coming to an end due to a devastating illness.
It was actually Kilmer's idea to have Iceman
be a mentor to Maverick, and he discussed his
ideas for the role with Cruise, Maverick director
Joseph Kosinski, and Jerry Bruckheimer. At first,
Kilmer types out his dialog to Cruise,
then he finally speaks, telling him:
"The Navy needs Maverick."
Watching the finished segment of Maverick
and Iceman together, Kilmer recalled:
"I was very moved the first time I saw it.
Almost 40 years is a long time for a reunion."
The door was always open for Iceman to return
in the second Top Gun film. The problem was
that Val Kilmer had survived a diagnosis of throat
cancer and now has trouble speaking as a result.
But with the help of today's technology,
Kilmer was able to return to Top Gun. Kilmer
worked with a company called Sonantic, who
created an A.I. voice that was put together
from hours of footage of Kilmer speaking in
movies. These recordings were then run into
algorithms to create a new voice for the
actor. As an executive at Sonantic said:
"In the end, we generated more than 40 different
voice models and selected the best,
highest-quality, most expressive one."
In the future, other actors will be able to
recreate their voices like this as well. Kilmer
said in a statement that he was grateful that
the company could restore his voice, and that:
"The chance to narrate my story, in a
voice that feels authentic and familiar,
is an incredibly special gift."